تشتهر منطقة تيغري في شمال إثيوبيا
بتجميعها للكنائس المحفورة في الصخور
[الموسيقى]
المنحوتة من الحجر الرملي ،
وأروع هذه الكنائس هي أبونا يامازاكي
[موسيقى]
هناك طريقة واحدة فقط
لتسلق هذا المنحدر الصخري مرحبًا بك
في معظم العالم  الكنيسة [الموسيقى] المحفوفة بالمخاطر التي
تأسست في القرن الخامس ،
سميت الكنيسة على اسم مؤسسها
وبانيها الأب يامادا التي
تطفو على ارتفاع 650 قدمًا فوق منحدر شديد الانحدار
يقول البعض إنه اختار موقعها ليكون
أقرب إلى الأرواح السماوية ،
ويقول البعض الآخر إنها كانت خطوة استراتيجية
لتجنبه  الأعداء في كلتا الحالتين
، جذبت اللوحات الجدارية الموجودة في سقف موقع الكنيسة
والكتاب المقدس المصنوع من جلد الماعز الثمين
المصلين لعدة قرون ، تضم الكنيسة
20 رجل دين ويديرها
كهنة رفيعو المستوى عاش هنا
منذ أكثر من 47 عامًا ، وهو يقوم بالتسلق
كل يوم وفي حالتي  كانت
ستقدمها كما قلت أنا وراء كيف
تعتقد أن المسيحية التي تعرفها قبل عام
الثوم - انظر ماذا - نعم لم
يكن الرجل رجلًا السيد.  Gotti
quaintest Olmec whoo yeah، you can have lost the mousie، yeah
[Music]
بالنسبة للمصلين الشجعان ،
يبدأ المسار الذي يستغرق ساعتان للوصول إلى الأعلى بالمشي لمسافات طويلة إلى
أسفل الصخرة من الوادي أدناه ،
يجب على الزائرين أولاً خلع أحذيتهم
قبل تسلق منطقة جوفاء معينة
بالنسبة له أيها المسلم المريح غاهاغان ها ها [ __ ]
لديه الأقمار الصناعية
الإيطالية العكسية فمن أنت رحمة
سخيفة وعشوائية بدون اسم حيث
نتعلم وبشكل عشوائي أن العقبة الأخيرة أمام
مدخل الكنيسة يمكن أن تختبر أكثر
الحجاج المتحمسين إيمانًا
بحافة جرف ضيقة مع  انخفاض مميت
إلى اليسار ولا مجال للخطأ
[موسيقى]
مرة واحدة من خلالك قد تعتقد أنك في
الجنة ولكنك لم تشعر أبدًا بأنك على قيد الحياة أكثر من أي
شخص بحق الجحيم ترى العمة Jade
Goody Asiata المسيحية يبيعون
لي الين ثم التالي  في يوم كنت مواطنًا بدرجة عالية
في معادلة منزل هونولولو ،
لقد صنعت [ __ ] الآن أحصل على
الأقدمية
[موسيقى]